on y va ça va et vient et court et court
celui-ci sera un petit peu loin mais
j'aime bien quand il est méchant mais
habillé sur ce gentil merci oui oui je
te connais oui le canadien allait aussi
au bayer avec lui en effet une cuisine
oui c'est vrai ça oui oui tout à fait oh
oui il est très ami avec mon meilleur
ami aussi à lorient non oui c'est dans
benoît solès qu'il y en avoir quatre
molières leucate molière c'est la
caution terme aussi mon meilleur ami a
eu quatre molières en soit nous met dans
les mots ni autiste la colère j'adore
jusque là les deux là ils sont comme des
fous là ils ont trouvé une valve et
evans est alors c'est un test
intéressant
à l'arrivée on sent alors c'est qu'ils
arrivent et le gala de la fondation du
pg lisant sa ruine en place les actions
pour aider les enfants notamment en
partenariat avec l'hôpital necker
oui il ya un million deux cent trente
mille euros qui ont été récoltés grâce à
toutes les généreuses personnalités qui
étaient présentes parmi elles le laurier
de la personne qui ou quel haye est
impossible de rater alors à cette soirée
toutes les stars s'étaient mis sur leur
trente-et-un vous faux nez vers ati
areola thomas schoorel dans ses lauriers
psg ou encore qu'il ya même bas p quand
tous sortis le super costa et pendant la
soirée tout le monde était très calme
discret solennel et pourtant dans un
coin y avait un gars à une table soldats
habillés comme un motard en train de
[ __ ] le bordel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce train de bon c'est comme ça je peins
paris bol d'or c'est une belle soirée
pas très belle soirée franchement rester
pour les enfants lorient c'était très
sympa vraiment voilà ouais bah voici
dommage on en parle ah bah non merci
merci c'est important
merci oui donc mardi donné c'est bien
sûr gad elmaleh que j'embrasse
sénégalais et un habitant exactement
alors mardi nous avons reçu l'excellent
laurent luyat analystes sportifs qui
venait pour son nouveau livre sur le
sport mais aussi pour faire la promotion
de roland garros
vraiment ce week end laurent lui à lui
les habitués à traîner avec nelson
monfort qui n'a pas de gros mots depuis
janvier les 86 et dans ses émissions de
sport et sa chambre un peu moins dans
touche pas à mon poste je pense que
laurent luyat n'oubliera jamais son
passage ici je lui remets le laurier de
l'invité qui reviendra avec plaisir mais
je pense qu'il va attendre un petit peu
comme quand il chante c'est incroyable
après tout si vous dit que laurent lui
la chambre comme un dieu alors forcément
vous avez envie de vérifier si c'est
vrai et c'est manifestement vous avez
apprécié la performance vocale
excuse moi tu trouves tu me fais tourner
lors je sens comme une merde
en plus ses chroniqueurs ont fait une
super promo à laurent luyat ça ça c'est
un livre s'attaque ici à solide par tous
c'est que des souvenirs pas là mais j'ai
pensé mais qui vous a donné la tendance
est important quand on aura quelqu'un
d'eurosport ici on fera les épiciers
j'ai proposé une idée géniale à laurent
luyat et je pense qu'il va vraiment y
réfléchir jour pendant tes commentaires
à roland garros ça serait très drôle que
il ya un mec qui paye donc federer ont
dû être un peu choqué par la différence
de langage avec sa mère ou dans l'ue où
vois tu vois la pression en train de
tout keno il vous quel est alors laissez
pas le rend lui à quel plus choqué par
le terme chiasse c'est valérie bénaïm
m
chiasse pour s imposer pour jamais le
dire faut jamais le dire ça me plaît ça
va sinon mathieu va très bien je simple
vérification mercy la gargouille
tiens tiens gargouilles et que sacha
toutefois c'est que c'est bon ce que
disait toujours ma grand mère ça va vous
ici si oui faites attention quand même
la fille de ben ali qui va à la chasse
perd sa place
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une avance sur roland garros
oui mais oui mais alors après non à une
info intéressante c'est nouveau
j'aimerais vous que la non mais on l'a
pas demandé nous sommes en forme ne
niera pas sur le court de tennis il est
interdit de saison là seront là on
l'avait vu on avait dit ça non mais on
n'en serait donc celle ci interdit
quotidien c'est rare qu'ils jouent
comment pourquoi
la fédération a choisi cette année que
de prendre des anciens joueurs pour
trouver les joueurs des salles dont tu
auras plus delson monfort sur le court
ce qui est dommage donc si vous voyez
qu'il a de la terre battue sur la gueule
sinon c'est comme ça on l'embrassé un
communiqué très important qui est tombée
aujourd'hui mais c'est vrai ah oui
j'avais une info tout à l'heure mais ça
a à voir avec roland garros non pas du
tout va bien pour l'instant c'est vrai
la météo cette année il ya 30 pensant de
proba qu'elle soit meilleure que la
dernière d'accord merci à couper le
souffle
sinon énergie hier soir on touche pas à
mon pot c'est là que te dise du chocolat
car déjà chocolat qui est un peu devenu
au traumatisme c'est vrai que si vous
mettez les chroniqueurs dans une pièce
avec un crocodile et du chocolat
en plus ce clan du chocolat c'est
incroyable c'est fou c'est incroyable
alors on va analyser ce qui s'est passé
hier soir ses lauriers d'animateurs qui
pourrait balancer du chocolat sur ses
chroniqueurs tous les jours pendant dix
ans
vous qu'en d'autres temps ci sont
retrouvés une dentellière aux reflets
chocolat
[Applaudissements]
série lui comme s'il avait braqué une
banque à l'afp
on va s'intéresser de près à trois
chroniqueurs qui en ont pris plein la
race on commence par jean-michel chipant
ong
il décale pour se protéger et bat milan
prend un énorme deuxième ça y est le
premier et hop le 2ème juste
kelly vous allez voir que kelly été
littéralement soulevés pour le chocolat
rien et moi ça sera à nancy la démence à
elle s'élever au delà il prône à fort
hills a b c le strike à elle entièrement
mouchetés ayoub el mar ap quelqu'un
isabelle sa noyade
[Musique]
si vous nous donnez leur j'avais fait
une digue credo kermabon excusé le mot
chocolat dalli est dictée c'est parti
j'ai voulu sauver isabelle est ce qu'on
peut revoir va le voir cette semaine à
tulle en avoir alors la sauver j'ai
voulu la sauver il est malheureusement
non alors c'est un coin parce que vous
avez tous remarqué que donc la belle
vous avez été terriblement chocolatées
et pourtant on l'a vu hier soir si vous
avez tout fait pour la sauver son
incroyable tous deux pareillement vous
obtenez le laurier de la seule personne
qui peut faire faire des disques et de
disques et d'éviter ces bleus plutôt que
panna cotta avec alain alors raymond et
comprend tout de suite que une
embrouille qui arrivent il sort direct
[Rires]
vous ne voulez pas quel sort pas ce que
voulait leur mettre plein la gueule mais
voulait absolument sauver isabelle et
bernard sauf que vous ne pouvez pas de
raison d'être inquiet même pratiqué tous
les deux vous êtes vous regardez comment
vous attrapez isabelle pour qu'elles
sont regardés
j'attendais de témoin n'a fait que me
l'émission avec vous dans les boues
connais pas alors mais forcément elle ne
bougera pas tant qu'on a pas de dicter
donc une minute après le bal en bien et
je me devais le filet de bave au
zimbabwe regardez maintenant regarder
[Applaudissements]
ajouté qu'au-delà s'atteler mieux
ensemble
elle doit faire deux films à mettre dans
les bêtisiers j'ai compris elle adore
les dictées beaucoup d'honneur provost
des sauveurs remo il a bel et bien là on
me demande ça depuis ce matin alors je
vais vous dire c'est vraiment vraiment
parce qu'il était fatigué vous devez on
a mangé à chaque fois mais on n'a jamais
voilà c'est ça exactement belle tu
sauves qu'isabelle parce que j'suis pas
je les trouvais belle voix là et puis je
savais qu'elle avait squash badminton
après c'est plus gris bernard montiel
il est des faits déjà beaucoup duvet je
suis à l'écouté voilà c'est pas vrai bon
voilà on est on verra pas le verra pas
le maître donc voilà donc voilà je vous
dis malheureusement isabelle a laissé
passer sa chance
voilà voilà mais pour l'instant
reconnaît sks que le chocolat est bon
alors c'est pas vraiment du chocolat
céréales de ces deux lots vous allez
savoir avec voilà du chocolat réalité du
chocolat à 2009
ok moi l'important c'est mettait pas de
l'air c'est d'accord ballon vous
inquiétez pas il ya pas de l'être pas
d'accord elle est d'accord pour en
prendre a dit je m'inquiétais pas ça
n'est pas chargé ce soir c'est comme
agen vainqueur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
juste un petit tacle à fond du coeur il
est temps de connaître celui ou celle
qui a remporté le 9e le résultat rabat
le pré catelan lui celui ou celle qui a
le plus tacler ses collègues
je rappelle que ça fait 8 fois que si
elle ne leur enfant alors j'ai
l'impression que c'est le cerveau nous
avait été beaucoup plus calme mais
franchement je le couvrais s concept
détrôner oui je pense que oui on sait
c'est vrai mais non non non non je dis
non et vous avez raison si vous n'êtes
encore et on va évidemment du texto en
bref j'étais couché thème la fin de ta
gueule
il a des anchois la place de choix ici
mon père n'est pas dit sa vérité c'est
vous qui payez ou c'est benjamin nana
s'en fout de ça on s'en fout c'est
l'hallali toujours mais je commence moi
je serai bientôt fini merci
mais en fait elle est là elle dans deux
heures par nuit en fait ce que vous
l'abri comme ça l'a 25 ans qu'est ce
qu'elle a c'est leur travail de dire
tout peut changer du tout et vous c'est
qu'au bout du monde doit avoir pour sait
très bien où était ce bois tout le week
end
[Applaudissements]